where do you go New York we need to buy
eggs milk or hot sandwich the bodega
in New York City institution but diggers
are literally everywhere in New York and
yes while some people think of them as
just grocery stores you can actually get
a whole lot more get on bacon and get
you loose our can we know what I got
still upon us in commuted I say water
the diggers are owned by different
ethnic groups like Puerto Ricans Yemenis
and Egyptians but the majority of
bodegas are owned by one community in
particular Dominican Americans that
business came to full fill that vacuum
that was there in the in the community
decades of immigration to the US have
made New York's Dominican diaspora the
largest in the world outside of the
Dominican Capital Santo Domingo this
immigration to the US has gifted us with
cardi B Junot Diaz David Ortiz Oscar de
la Renta and the kid Miro who actually
has a podcast called
la bodega boys hey guys I'm onion and
today I want to explore how but Degas
became so essential to New York life and
also how the story of Dominican
immigration to the US was instrumental
in making it happen
we spoke to dorky Gomez owner of Gold
Glove deli and grocery she's on her
bodega in New York's Washington Heights
neighborhood for over a year and is
known as a friendly face to customers
cuando una persona viene de del del
parte como la semana so developer
community Ana's compo Cody ha no puedo
hablar con esta persona
they still a Darla motiva see on ice a
persona of a que toda los caminos and
assisting in a bodega you can find a
wide variety of products la bodega tiene
un poco de todo en the area
any person on a Pharmacia commis a baby
Dominica not an anisotropic Gomez
emigrated to the u.s. from the Dominican
Republic or dr 2016 perjure brother
Carlos is a major league baseball player
with the Tampa Bay Rays and helped her
establish her bodega from Pocatello
facing como todos commercial zombie MVCC
ya que tienen trabajo constant a pair o
sister o bro Kobe's and her family live
in the building
she works hard to support her husband
and one-year-old son she says that even
though Dominicans are far from their
homeland but they just help them feel
closer to one another become father open
to the gold is a store looks like your
typical bodega for starters there's a
yellow and red sign and you can be
usually by lot idea or a lottery ticket
at the counter
you're probably spot a candle or Villa
Laura painted with religious imagery
somewhere in the shop and you'll
probably see a bodega cat roaming around
or is sleep in the middle of the floor
and in case you didn't know bodega cats
are a big deal
there are Instagram and Twitter accounts
and Facebook pages and bodega cats are
so iconic that this New York Lottery
even used them in their commercial super
cute okay so while Dominicans like Gomez
have dominated the bodega scene in New
York for decades the bodega story didn't
exactly start with them Jewish delis
that sold a whole range of products were
a common scene across New York starting
in the 1920s familiarizing the city with
the concept of corner stores but it was
in the 1940s and 50s that bodegas as we
know them today first became a part of
New York's social fabric
initially they were established by
Puerto Ricans who moved to New York
post-world War two
from the u.s. Island territory and
that's something that professor Ramona
have numbness argues is often lost in
the conversation about bodega Dominicans
bought bodegas the bodegas from Puerto
Rican owners who were leaving New York
City as Dominicans were coming in so
they were the one working in the bodegas
for Puerto Ricans when the transition
happened during the same time the dr was
experiencing some major political and
economic upheaval for starters the
Dominican Republic's us back dictator
elder hill was assassinated in 1961
Peter assassination of led to successive
events interrelated in provoking the
exodus of the Dominican people in 1962
the country voted for its first freely
elected president Juan Bosch
but his pro-castro sentiments angered
the u.s. and parts of the Dominican
government we need to remember cuban
revolution has just taking place a few
years before it wasn't the best idea to
have another country in the Caribbean or
even in America latina with a similar
system this led to a military coup an
installation of the us-backed Joaquin
Balaguer
as president but all of this people
created huge Andres prompting a civil
war and then in 1965 the u.s. invaded it
was Dominicans fighting Dominicans and
now this is 1965 and the US gets
involved and now he becomes Dominicans
fighting the u.s. this turmoil left
Dominicans seeking both safety and
economic security so in an effort to win
hearts and minds the US government made
it easier for Dominicans to settle here
reasons for their massive migration have
to do with the economic conditions of
the Dominican migrants in LA and the
Dominican Republic and for the
Dominicans immigrating to the US but it
has made practical sense these are small
businesses that allow Dominicans to have
a job another center and provide for
their family and this in many instances
were created because they were not able
to find jobs and the larger economy in
the larger society but at the same time
it also represents independence there
were several waves of Dominican
immigration since then today they are
the fifth largest Latino group in the
country with more than 600,000
Dominicans in New York alone in New York
the Washington Heights neighborhood is
the heart of the Dominican community in
the past this neighborhood was home to
Irish immigrants and European Jews then
in the 60s and 70s
Dominicans moved in they eventually
became the majority establishing one of
the most recognized ethnic enclaves in
New York Washington Heights has this
random tradition already so the other
thing is that Washington Heights it's
very close to al wakil which is a
settlement and neighborhood populated at
that time predominantly by Puerto Ricans
and one thing that we know is that
Dominicans move in the u.s. or tend to
live in areas where you also find what
we can walk in through Washington
Heights you'll see Dominican restaurants
and beauty salons you also hear bachata
merengue and then Bo and of course lots
and lots of bodegas the bodega it is
this place that served at the same time
as a social space where Dominicans
converge persona que meaning a
consummate a la bodega hermanita no sisa
same thing a mohamed knows in the
difficult ascent fo cocoa
singing look at hearing but bodegas are
much more than corner stores where you
get your diapers or Platanos it's a
place where the community gathers to
hang out and grab a bite but diggers are
also a resource for low-income and
immigrant communities they often serve
areas where you won't find a supermarket
and bodegas often acts as lifelines for
many neighborhoods in the city by
letting customers who are short on cash
pay for their items later anybody tries
to help by the people coming there
they're sure or they they need a certain
item and they don't have the money at
the time then what do our best to
accommodate them and this is why bodega
is are so special they allow for a
relationship between the bodega dough's
and their clients for a bodega owner
ganado out a condition that means that
his store is much more than that our
ganja houses homeless folks in the
basement of his bodega and has done so
for years Vinayaka
you're yelling Elsie
despite his bodega beam zone strictly
for commercial use and not having the
proper permits to house individuals he's
taking it upon himself to provide
shelter for them
hey kid I have to go me or you where we
check on a mom with a turkey you're a
stark American Gail immigrated from the
DRT vos in 1989 he bought his bodega in
1995 and began taking in homeless people
shortly after William Arroyo
has lived in the basement of ARCA hands
bodega for five years totally listen and
you give me saying while they here and
that's history you know he's a great
person very great pretty and sure but
Degas can be profitable but they also
struggle with challenges that so many
businesses in big cities in the u.s.
face today
rising costs and gentrification in 2015
an estimated 75 well they got shut down
in New York because of rent increases
according to the Real Estate Board of
New York went went up over a third from
2004 2014 and well that's a small number
of the estimated 12,000 bodegas
scattered across New York it's hit the
industry pretty hard
not to mention the community in
Washington Heights gentrification has
definitely impacted the Dominican people
affluent people have discovered the
great location of Washington Heights
that's what it is it is I mean it is an
incredible location despite the
difficulties bodegas have faced in
recent years the community is still very
proud of its heritage and contributions
to the United States and Dominicans are
much more than their bodegas being able
to contribute and produce in the society
where we now live for more than that
preserve in legacy a cultural legacy
historical legacy right here and share
it with the rest of society entonces yo
creo que se una forma de nosotros be
presented a chemistry boot Americana
presented an overdose avocados
Latinos venomous a trabajar bien
boo-yah gravamen decades device hey guys
over the next couple of weeks we're
gonna take a close look at diasporas in
the u.s. who do you think we should
cover next please let us know in the
comments and don't forget to Like share
and subscribe